hi I'm Evan Carmichael walked with to
another edition of modeling the Masters
today's post is brought to you by
American Express they recently launched
a Facebook page called Amex for business
Canada that has a lot of resources tips
tools information for entrepreneurs that
I hope you'll go check out now I believe
that the fastest and most effective way
to grow your business is to model the
strategies of people who've already done
what you're trying to do so today we're
gonna look at how an engineer discovered
that engineering wasn't his passion and
he wanted to be a businessman against
the advice of his friends and family and
everyone around them he left his
high-paying job to go back to school get
an MBA and into the business world he
went on to become one of the richest
people in Canada this is a story of Bret
Wilson and a top three lessons you can
learn from his success Brett Wilson a
Canadian engineer businessman and
television personality is best known for
his appearances on CBC's dragons dead
after growing up at a middle-class
family his father a car salesman and
mother of social worker Wilson went off
to college to study engineering he would
get his bachelor's degree in engineering
and go to work for one of the old
companies in Western Canada however
after a few years of working as an
engineer he discovered that he wanted to
do something else
business after going to school to get
his MBA Wilson would join nine of the
friends to start an investment club they
each put in $200 and invested in the
stock market they would soon each get
back 221 dollars but more importantly
understanding how the stock market
worked how commissions work how to buy
and sell stocks as well as learn to
research and watch market trends it
wasn't much money but this small
investment club got Wilson moving and
drove him to wanting to do more in the
business world he would go on to work
for an investment bank but his
entrepreneurial spirit was still not
satisfied he would bite his time network
make contacts I learned everything he
could so one day he could start his own
business finally he would create his own
investment advisory firm and later team
up with three partners to create a
brokerage firm first energy capital that
would offer investment services to the
oil and gas industry today first energy
capital has handled more than 150
billion dollars worth of mergers
acquisitions and asset sales Wilson has
been named one of the top 20 deal makers
in Canada and one of the top 10 mergers
and acquisition specialists in Canada by
following his gut a my not listening to
the people who didn't believe in him
Brett Wilson was able to go from an
engineer to a highly successful
entrepreneur to help you explode your
business
here are three auction items and you can
learn from Brett Wilson action item
number one stay the course most people
have ideas to start businesses but they
don't take action it's scary
it takes a lot of courage you might fail
and it's outside the normal corporate
world that most people are used to it
takes a lot of guts to start a business
and in many cases your friends and
family won't understand why you're doing
it they may tell you you're crazy and
you should get a comfortable job so you
don't have to worry if your passion
about being an entrepreneur don't let
the naysayers get you down focus on why
you're running your business and keep
jumping over the hurdles putting your
way until you reach the success you're
after Wilson believes that real
entrepreneurs have to stay the course
even when your friends and family don't
think what you're doing is a good idea
Wilson started out his career as an
engineer and had a good job in the oil
fields but was missing the passion when
he wanted to change careers and focus on
business his family and friends tried to
convince him that he had a good job and
she'd stick it out he then took a
management test at his engineering job
and failed it they told him that he was
not management material Wilson had to
prove everyone wrong so he left his job
and started following his passion
according to Wilson it was hard not to
enjoy the success we were having doing a
deal a day it was enthralling to be at
the office
I got as caught up in my career as any
investment banker could be I worked for
about three years as an engineer one of
the big oil companies
I discovered that I wasn't passionate
about engineering I was passionate about
business despite being told by one of my
first employers that I wasn't management
material I enrolled in the MBA program
at the University of Calgary I was the
first graduate to major in
entrepreneurship after I started my
business a company named Wilson Mackey
my dad asked me if I was still looking
for a job
entrepreneurs have to be willing to stay
the course even when those closest to
you question what you're doing option
number two watch and learn when I
started my first real company about tech
software business I was 19 years old
and didn't have a clue what I was doing
I was in over my head and didn't want to
fail my aha moment came when I realized
that I wasn't the first guy to try to
sell software so our research companies
like Microsoft McAfee and Intuit to see
how they got started by looking at how
Bill Gates grew his company he became my
mentor even though I had never met him
you can learn a lot about how to market
your business and build your company by
following the success clues that those
before you have left behind Wilson had
completed his education in both
engineering and business but the course
he found most valuable was consumer and
buyer behavior today he believes this
course taught him the proper way to
market and how to brand businesses his
most valuable skill is watching and
learning watching her other businesses
do to create brand awareness and how
each successfully competed for capital
he desperately wants others to
understand his behaviors and spends a
lot of time trying to pass this
information along to other aspiring
entrepreneurs according to Wilson it
doesn't matter if you're a doctor
scientist engineer or lawyer the tools
of marketing are invaluable I sometimes
think people over worry this take me
under your wing notion people can be
mentored by simply observing carefully
for example I've been mentored by
Richard Branson in the marketing world
and a variety of business people in
terms of
their business acumen I watch and learn
and I'm still watching and learning
actually not on number three grow during
hard times when times get tough
entrepreneurs often scale back question
of their cut out to be a business owner
and often go looking for a job when the
economy is doing poorly the successful
entrepreneurs look at it as an
opportunity for growth they realized
that the competition is likely not
invested in marketing or new innovations
and that there's a lot of talented
people who are looking for work to grow
through tough times you need to get
closer to your customer and develop new
products and services that can help them
solve important pains that they are
facing Wilson grew his business to the
hard times our being innovative he
believes that entrepreneurs who focus on
building a culture of innovation always
look for ways to be better improved more
efficient and do things more
intelligently if you can't find a
solution create one if you're constantly
innovating you'll have some failures but
your successes will help you not just
get through hard times but grow through
them according to Wilson innovators
thinkers are constantly asking a
question how can we make things better
no matter what stage you write in your
career what industry you work in
everyone around you can benefit from new
ideas don't be afraid to think outside
the box just because something works
doesn't mean it can't be better don't
expect not to be afraid
real courage is being scared to death
and going ahead anyway hard times are an
opportunity for growth struggle doesn't
so much build character as reveal it so
remember stay the course
watch and learn and grow during hard
times to finish up the video I wanted to
share one of my favorite true stories
about Brett Wilson and some of his best
quotes
when Wilson was young his father set him
up a job cutting the neighbors lawn all
summer long Wilson said he knew a friend
that was making $3 for each cut I
thought it was a good way to make some
extra money for the summer he mowed the
lawn twice a week for a total of 30 cuts
at the end of the summer he went to
collect his summer wages and she handed
him of $10 bill
Wilson was flabbergasted he expected $90
instead of the $10 she'd given him he
would later be quoted as saying as he
looked back on his life
I didn't negotiate a price up front I
learned a lot about communicating and
being upfront and establishing mutual
expectations in hindsight a great
learning experience and for a great
cause the widdled neighbor
thank you for joining me for another
edition of maudlin masters if you like
the video I want to see more please give
it a thumbs up below I'd also love to
hear what you have to think if you want
to leave a comment under the video also
remember to check out the MX with
Pistons Canada Facebook page and we'll
see you on the next episode
you